[music]
>> The next
authentic source
after the Quran
is the Hadith.
That's
the sayings and actions of the beloved
Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam. I think in the notes it is put
on the last page.
Last page it is.
Last page.
Now, as far as
Ya Allah, we'll be running short of
time.
Normally, if you have heard my speeches,
those of you who are most of you
I always say Quran
and Hadith. Quran authentic Hadith. Most
of them say Quran and Hadith.
Now, Hadith means
the sayings
and actions of the Prophet.
What the Prophet said
that becomes a source of knowledge and
Hujjah for us.
Again, in saying there's something what
he said, something what he commanded. We
are not going to cross on Hadith.
But, the commandment of the prophet
Muhammad carried a great weight and it
is a Hadith for us
and we believe even this Hadith has been
preserved
in the authentic form. The Hadith that
we have are various. There are sahih
Hadith, there are zaif Hadith.
There are mawdu Hadith. There are
different classifications of Hadith.
Time will not permit us to go into
detail, but broadly there are three
classifications: sahih, zaif, and mawdu.
Sahih, zaif, and mawdu. Sahih means
authentic, zaif means weak, mawdu means
fabricated. So, whenever you use as a
Hadith
as argument as a proof, only sahih
Hadith is
acceptable. You can take zaif Hadith,
not that you can't, but that doesn't
become as a Hadith.
If there is no text in the Quran or the
Hadith and you use a zaif Hadith and
say, "Okay, it can be used." Yes, it has
got its importance. I'm not saying it
has no importance, but as a Hadith
as a proof that okay, this is far or
haram in Islam
it should either be from the Quran or
the sahih Hadith.
If you quote a zaif Hadith, that cannot
be a Hadith as a far. It may be right.
Zaif Hadith means that it has got
weaknesses. Mawdu means it's concocted.
How to identify a Hadith is sahih? There
are rules and regulations, there are
criteria. This is not a lecture on
Hadith.
As I said, it's not a knowledge-based
program. There are different categories
of
rawi, narrators. The muhaddithin, it's
art.
Normal people feel they have less
knowledge of Quran, only Quran.
Hadith though
because they don't know the science of
Hadith. Anyone who knows the science of
Hadith, alhamdulillah, the muhaddithin
that those who are experts on Hadith
have done such a beautiful work that
it's a scientific art
to identify whether Hadith is sahih or
not. You and I, we are laymen.
We can't do that.
We quote after the work has been done by
the muhaddithin.
You as a layman cannot do surgery.
I'm a bachelor so little bit I can do.
But if you see blood blood blood you run
away. What is the blood? I am cutting to
save the patient.
Oh, person is CUTTING USING A KNIFE.
Killing killing what killing?
I
He is cutting you can see blood to save
him.
So layman we think who doesn't know
about surgery is cutting blood run away.
He is an expert.
These modest in mashallah have compiled
all the works and the lifestyle of all
the narrators called as Ravi and they
have categorized them into 12
categories. One is sick car number one
means all authentic. They are the
Sahabas.
Then category two, category three,
category four last is category 12 the
cause up the liars.
Yeah, I'm going to do a course on
Hadith.
And neither am I a modest and I'm just a
student of knowledge.
Yes, I have spoken to modest things and
met them and talked with them
alhamdulillah. So what I'm telling you
is my having sessions of few hours with
one of the top scholars available in the
world alhamdulillah.
I don't have a degree from any
university.
I have a degree of doctor medical
doctor.
Alhamdulillah then I got
an honorary PhD from Gambia honorary I
don't consider.
I'm just a student of knowledge
alhamdulillah.
So Hadith when we quote Quran and say
Hadith.
Again the category of say Hadith
the category of say Hadith again there
are different categorization of Hadith.
Whether it's modest Hadith and this and
that. Amongst one of the categorizations
in the Hadith
the say Hadith again
are further classified into 10
categories.
One is mutafiq alayh. Mutafiq alayh
means common in Bukhari and Muslim.
Before we go to Bukhari and Muslim let
me tell you
that many people have a misconception
when they say Siyasetta.
Do you know about Siyasetta?
Siyasetta
No about Siyasetta.
What is the meaning of Sihah Sitta?
Give the microphone here.
The six books of Hadith, uh
Imam Bukhari's Sahih al-Bukhari, Imam
Muslim's Sahih Muslim, Imam Tirmidhi's
Imam Nasa'is uh Sunan uh Sunan Nasa'i,
and Ibn Majah.
What is the meaning of Sihah Sitta?
The uh classified as Sahih books. Is it
correct or is it wrong? Uh there is
classes, first class, second class, and
third class, which
>> The word Sihah Sitta, I know you told in
the introduction that you have got your
scholar's degree. I'm speaking to a
scholar, I am a student.
Yesterday you said in the introduction
No, you said that. I heard it.
Alhamdulillah, you may be a scholar, I
don't know.
But again, the word Sihah Sitta,
the six authentic books is a misnomer.
It's a
What is the meaning of misnomer?
Misnomer means a wrong terminology.
Sihah Sitta is a wrong terminology
normally used
in many Islamic universities including
India, Pakistan. Sihah Sitta means six
authentic books. It is a misnomer.
No, people call Muslims that Muhammadan.
Muhammadan is the right word?
Is Muhammadan a right word
to call to a Muslim? It's a
misnomer because we don't worship
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam. We
love him. We revere him. We obey him. We
follow him, but we don't worship him.
Correct? So, Muhammadan is a misnomer.
Same, Sihah Sitta is a misnomer. The
right word is Kutub Sitta.
It is not Sihah Sitta. But in Indian
most Sihah Sitta Sihah Sitta I have an
hour Sihah Sitta.
Sihah Sitta means the Sahih
six books. No.
It is Kutub Sitta.
Means the six books.
Kutub books.
Sitta means six. Sihah means Sahih.
So, it's not six authentic set of books.
And we know the six books that is there.
Even these six differ
in the scholars.
The which six to take also differs.
Bukhari is there, Muslim is there, Abu
Dawud is there, Tirmidhi is there, then
Ibn Majah
and
Nasa'i. Some scholars say no, Ibn Majah
should not be Imam Muwatta Malik should
be there. Differ. We don't go into the
details. It's not a class of Hadith.
But anyway, all the seven books are
Sihah Sittah is a misnomer because all
six books are not authentic.
There's Ijma'
among the scholars, only two set of
books
Hadith collections, that is Bukhari and
Muslim, all authentic.
These two are the only set of books
which are 100% authentic. The remaining
four,
Abu Dawud, Nasa'i,
Tirmidhi, and Ibn Majah or Imam Muwatta
Malik, all the Hadith in them, most of
them are Sahih, not all.
Very important. So, if someone quotes
you Bukhari, khalas.
As a layman, you agree to Sahih. Someone
quotes you Muslim, but check up if it's
there. Many people quote Bukhari, it's
not there in Bukhari.
Okay, ask them for a friend. Chapter
number, Hadith number, okay, check if
it's there. If it's Bukhari, as a
layman, you accept it is.
There are scholars who have said, okay,
one or two Hadith here or there. We
don't go into that.
That is a PhD level, whether or not one
or two may not be right or wrong. As a
whole, we accept
that all the Hadith in Bukhari are
Sahih.
All the Hadith in Muslim are Sahih.
All the Hadith in the other four books,
most of them are Sahih, but not all.
It's Ijma' amongst all the scholars,
amongst all the Muhaddithin.
Because the main purpose of Imam Abu
Dawud or Imam Tirmidhi
or Ibn Majah wasn't to collect only
Sahih.
But in Bukhari and Muslim, these two
Imams, their main purpose was besides
compiling only compiling what is sahih
and nothing else.
So, only two set of books
of Hadith
100% authentic
it is the collection
done by Imam Bukhari and Imam Muslim.
The other four,
alhamdulillah, most of them are correct.
But why do we use this word Kutub
al-Sittah? We use this word Kutub
al-Sittah means if you read these six
books
of Hadith, you will know most of the
important factors of Islam. Not 100%,
but most.
Because Hadith, there are many.
There are a million Hadith. We'll come
to it later on.
Now, where are we going to read a
million?
So, the scholars say, if you read these
six books, majority of the fiqh
of the usul, of the derivations is
there.
Almost all, if not all. Most of it. So,
that's right.
But among all the books, the most
authentic is Bukhari.
La ilaha illallah. [music]
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun Rasulullah.
Muhammadun [music]
Rasulullah.
Arju ridhaka ya Allah.
>> Antar Rahimu ya Allah. Habni ataka
>> ya Allah. Antal Karimu
minka atao
ya Allah. Antal Azimu ya Allah. Fikar
Rajao ya
>> Allah. Antal Halimu
Ar-Rahmanu as-Sattaru [music]
Malikul Mulki al-Ghaffaru al-Wahhabu
al-Mannanu al-Muta'al.
Ar-Rahmanu as-Sattaru Malikul Mulki
al-Ghaffaru al-Wahhabu al-Mannanu
al-Muta'al.
>> [chanting]
>> All Rahman
>> [music]